وكان جونكر بمنسق والاتصالات في مجلس
الامن القوميه الامريكيه قال من حقي تركيا
دفع ما وصفه بالارهاب عن نفسها غير انه
اشار الى معارضتي بلاده لاي تحرك قد يؤثر
على مواصله الحرب على تنظيم الدوله او
ايقاع ضحايا بين المدنيين
للهجمات الارهابيه ان كان بالقرب من
حدودها او داخل البلاد ولها الحق في
الدفاع عن نفسها ومواطنها ضد الاعتداءات
ما قلناه ايضا هو اننا نريد ان نرى تخفيضا
للتصعيد ولا نريد ان نرى ايه اعمال قد
تؤدي اولا الى وقوع ضحايا اضافيين خاصه
المدنيين وثانيا لا نريد ان نرى اي فعل من
شانه الاضرار بجهودنا لمواصلات العمل مع
نظراءنا السوريين ضد تنظيم داعش والذي ما
يزال تهديدا حقيقيا داخل العراق وسوريا
وعلينا ان نواصل الضغط عليه